we are taken into the Islamic states
last stronghold after a final night of
heavy bombardment this is where the
so-called Caliphate ended as we enter
the center of bagus the convoy stops
there's still one area of resistance a
militant Mattoon come on swatter ban SDF
forces move us back whilst the last
blows are delivered
we're still hearing the sporadic sound
of gunfire the last pocket of is it's
just over there
but what we're witnessing are the final
moments of the Islamic state this is a
significant victory for the Syrian
democratic forces and it has taken a
long time in coming but although is is
defeated on the battlefield this isn't
the end of the group it's likely now to
go underground and fight a guerrilla
insurgency eventually the guns do fall
silence and we journey into a dark
apocalyptic hellscape corpse is rotting
in the pallid spring Sun the stench is
everywhere blown on the desert winds
it is an unbelievable sight a wasteland
this is where the Islamic state made its
last standard a junkyard encampment you
can see in the distance bedsheets and
costs that have been erected as tents
there's more over here and you can see
how the fighters work we're living these
tunnels and foxholes under here which
would help them evade the bombardment
from the coalition jets and artillery
but this is really all that now is left
of what once was the Islamic state for
the Kurdish forces this victory is
traced with sadness many died as martyrs
in what was a global fight the future of
their people is also far from secure it
is why the declaration is a surreal
moment an understated ceremony on a
rooftop overlooking the Euphrates River
the commander who led the fight
confirming Isis's rule is over
[Music]
the road to the end of the Islamic state
is a journey through destroyed
communities town after battered town
tells a story of years of fighting to
break the group's poisonous stranglehold
on Iraq and Syria what comes next will
depend on whether there can be effective
government and how these regions are
reconstructed whilst the victory is
complete there are still areas that need
searching for Isis fighters more often
than not the soldiers tasked with the
duty are shooting at shadows the ghosts
of Isis will haunt these places for a
long time to come the desperation and
the inglorious final stand of the group
though is hugely damaging to its brand
but even with its flag in tatters it
still has the resources to rise up from
this and strike again